there's also some congratulating to do
in your personal life mmm you made a
reveal today that you have been married
yes I married Satan no your boyfriend of
23 years yes yes
why was right now the time to get
married in light of what's happening
currently in the world today what's
happening in Washington thought you know
what let's do it let's just do it
because uh there's too much there's too
much at stake with with our businesses
and you know yeah so that's what we did
it has life changed it all with that
piece of paper no no this is the thing
that paper don't mean nothing new people
don't mean nothing if you're devoted to
a person nothing's gonna change that and
after you know 24 years you know uh hey
you know what I know him he knows me I
love him he's my favorite person on the
planet I've met metal lucky I met a lot
of people he's my favorite person I met
him on the dance floor at limelight
literally on the dance floor Klein he
was dancing like a crazy person I I
wonder was it what what are you doing
you know and that was that but uh yeah
he's a rancher he has a ranch in Wyoming
a very large ranch is that where you
guys live most of the time no no um he
he works the ranch I work Hollywood and
we um meet up in fabulous places you
know he needs brakes
sometimes I'm cuz it's a it's a very
different life you know so we we planned
a you know little getaways once a month
you know New York or Maui or Tampa just
go Vegas and we do that you found what
works for you guys it works you know you
know mug you know this concept of
marriage that we were you know raised
with it's so different from the real
style of relationships that that linger
for years and years it takes a real
commitment to be able to stick with
someone no matter what and see them as
as their authentic self it's real life
each real life it's very different from
what they show on TV you know where or
in the movies or in songs it's very
different
did you have a full-on wedding or did us
go courthouse no we had we had a friend
of ours
Marius at our house here in LA and it
was just very very low-key right because
it's something I love you know I don't
usually don't put my relationship out in
the public is it something that's
private if it's separate from you know
yes you know it's it's real it's real
[Music]